what to you
is beautiful about the study of biology
the science the engineering the
philosophy of it
it's a very interesting question i must
say at one level
it's not a conscious thing i can say a
lot about
why as an adult i find biology
compelling but
as a kid i was completely fascinated
with
animals i loved to watch them and think
about why they did
what they did and that developed into a
very conscious
passion as an adult but i think uh
in the same way that one is drawn to a
person
i was drawn to
the never ending series of
near miracles that exists across
biological nature
when you see a living organism do you
see it from an
evolutionary biology perspective of like
this entire thing that moves around in
this world
or do you see like from an engineering
perspective
they're like uh first principles almost
down to the physics like the little
components that build up
hierarchies that you have cells if the
first proteins and
cells and organs and all that kind of
stuff so do you see low level
or do you see high level well the human
mind is a strange thing
and i think it's probably a bit like a
time
sharing machine in which i have
different modules
we don't know enough about biology for
them to connect right so they exist in
isolation
and i'm always aware that they do
connect but i basically have to step
into
a module in order to see the
evolutionary dynamics
of the creature and the lineage that it
belongs to
i have to step into a different module
to think of that lineage over a very
long time scale
a different module still to understand
what the mechanisms
inside would have to look like to
account for what we can see
from the outside and
i think that probably sounds really
complicated but
one of the things about being involved
in a topic like
biology and doing so for one you know
really not even just my adult life for
my whole life
is that it becomes second nature and you
know when when we see somebody
do an amazing parkour routine or
something
like that we think about what they must
be doing
in order to accomplish that but of
course what they are doing
is tapping into some kind of zone right
there
in a zone in which they are in such
command of their center of gravity for
example that they
know how to hurl it around a landscape
so that they always
land on their feet and
i would just say for anyone who hasn't
found a topic
on which they can develop that kind of
facility it is
absolutely worthwhile it's really
something that human beings are capable
of doing across a wide range of topics
many things our ancestors didn't even
have access to
and that flexibility of humans that
ability to
repurpose our machinery for
topics that are novel means really
the world is your oyster you can you can
figure out what your passion is and then
figure out
all of the angles that one would have to
pursue to really deeply understand it
and it is uh it is well worth having at
least one topic like that
you mean embracing the full adaptability
of the
both the the body and the mind so like
because i don't know what to attribute
to parkour too
like biomechanics of how our bodies can
move
or is it the mind like how much percent
wise
is it the entirety of the
hierarchies of biology that we've been
talking about or is it just
all the mind the way to think about
creatures is that every creature
is two things simultaneously a creature
is a machine of sorts right it's not a
machine in
in the you know it's it's i call it an
aqueous machine
right and it's run by an aqueous
computer right so it's not identical to
our technological machines but
every creature is both a machine that
does things in the world
sufficient to accumulate enough
resources to continue
surviving to reproduce it is also a
potential
so each creature is potentially
for example the most recent common
ancestor of some future clade of
creatures that will look very different
from it
and if a creature is very very good at
being a creature but not
very good in terms of the potential it
has going forward
then that lineage will not last very
long into the future because
change will throw at challenges that its
descendants will not be able to meet
so the thing about humans is we are
a generalist platform and
we have the ability to swap out our
software
to exist in many many different niches
and i was once watching a an interview
with
with this uh british group of parkour
experts who were
being you know just they were discussing
what it is they do and how it works and
what they essentially said is
look you're tapping into deep
monkey stuff right and i thought yeah
that's about right
and you know anybody who
is proficient at something like skiing
or skateboarding
you know has the experience of
flying down the hill on skis for example
bouncing
from the top of one mogul to the next
and
if you really pay attention you will
discover that your conscious mind is
actually a spectator
it's there it's involved in the
experience but it's not driving some
part of you knows how to ski and it's
not the part of you that knows how to
think
and i would just say that the
what accounts for this flexibility in
humans
is the ability to bootstrap a new
software program
and then drive it into the unconscious
layer where it can be applied very
rapidly
and you know i will be shocked if the
exact
thing doesn't exist in robotics you know
if you
if you programmed a robot to deal with
circumstances that were novel to it how
would you do it it would have to look
something like this
there's a certain kind of magic you're
right
with the consciousness being an observer
when you play guitar for example
or piano for me music when you get truly
lost in it
i don't know what the heck is
responsible for the flow of the music
the kind of
the loudness of the music going up and
down the timing
the intricate like even the mistakes all
those things that doesn't seem to be the
conscious mind
uh it's it is just observing and yet
it's somehow
intricately involved more like because
you mentioned parkour
the dance is like that too when you
start i've been tango dancing
you if when you truly lose yourself in
it
then it's just like you're an observer
and how the hell is the body able to do
that
and not only that it's the physical
motion it's also creating
the emotion the
like that damn is good to be alive
feeling so
but then that's also intricately
connected to the full biology stack
that we're operating in
you